ladies ladies and gentlemen
thank you thank you so much for joining
us for this very special session of the
world economic Forum we have had many
extraordinary conversations here but I
think this one is going to be uh truly
special and we have uh an address by a
world leader and then a panel of world
leaders to discuss what is really the
central issue in the world today which
is Russia's war on Ukraine the West's
response the world's response uh and
where that will go
to start us off you know they sometimes
say uh there are people who need no
introduction I think that this might be
the definition of of such a person but I
think there's another definition that
comes to mind I think that in in uh in
years to come when dictionaries are
trying to decide how to use describe and
Define the word courage they might say
such equality as president zielinski of
Ukraine demonstrated during the Russian
invasion of his country so without any
any further Ado the first order of
businesses we will hear directly from
Kiev live from the from the president of
Ukraine I will take one second before to
just let you all know that we have a
very special situation right now which
is the first lady of Ukraine is in the
audience and she will be watching her
husband Mr President
[Applause]
foreign
ladies and gentlemen
10 hours
10 hours ago a transition
happens near key
the helicopter crash
planned lives of the minister
of the internal affairs of Ukraine
his police and helicopter
when it found nearer a kindergarten
fortino Ukrainian families lost their
loved ones today and many anymore
losing deal
because
enough
I shall ask you to honor the memory of
every person praying is lost without a
minute of Silence
[Music]
foreign
thank you for this
minutes
only one minutes
but it keeps the memory about so many
people
Ukraine lives thousands of such units
including three minutes on January 14th
three minutes
the time it took for a Russian missile
to travel hundreds of kilometers hit a
residential walking in Europe until at
least 45 people
45 and as children from 45.
my address will be sure about the time
we are short off about small minutes
about years made of these units
three years ago I spoke and divorced for
the first time in person
the topic was how to build
a
cohesive and sustainable world I'm
talking online now
and they thought I guess how to
cooperate in
and divided fragmented world
conclusions
the world cannot keep the base with
changes and challenges
the list of Crisis Global Security
environmental food security energy must
needs to be amended with another one
the Time Crisis
the list of course for decisive
efficient joint actions needs to be
extended with one more
the call for Spirit the spirit of
decisions making reaction of the
Civilized world
tragedies are outpacing Life The Tyranny
is outpacing
the democracy
Russia needed less than one second to
start the war the wall needed it this to
react with the first sanctions
the time the Free World uses to think is
used by the terrorist state to kill you
Ukraine and its allies have been
resisting it for almost a year this
period proved all our prompt actions
brought positive results
the opening of European borders who you
pronounced the brain deal
millions millions of lives and not only
do you pray
it is not only Ukraine but the whole
world needs exactly this space of
decisions and actions
the world was
hesitant in 2014 when Russia without
hesitation occupying the Crimea the
world was hesitant in 2012 when Russia
without hesitation made the world full
escape the wall must not hesitate today
and ever
Russia is exporting Terror Russia is
spreading their strain of the world a
global war Ukraine offers the wall a
peace formula please 10 steps that the
world must make faster than Russia makes
its new moves
mobilization on the wall must out face a
next military mobilization of our
insurance enemy
discipline of Ukraine with air defense
systems must outpace Russia's next
missile attacks the supplies for Western
tanks must outpace another invasion of
Russian tanks the restoration of
Securities and at peace in Ukraine must
outface Russia's attacks on security and
peace in other countries
a Tribunal for military crimes must
prevent new ones the extension of Nature
and the EU must outgo the spread of the
Russian breasts we routinely defend
values which some of the Allies take for
granted as a fact of life for us the
effect of life in the world in need of
resonance and prom steps
three years ago was my first time at the
Wes it was the time when the world was
fighting covid-19 it was it
fought and won
now the world is fighting against
Buddhism
in three years we will be discussing new
challenges
and threats in divorce
what will this mean it will mean we will
definitely overcome the current threat
the history
remixed itself
has helped the world either fails to
know this horror
other estimates a threat then it unites
to resist it and then the world wins
every time
the same alcohol
the world overcame Nazism
the apartheid
lyrics the indifference to climate
changes financial crisis and the Kremlin
Australia the world will overcome again
this is how much can be set in a matter
of minutes this is how much can be
understood in a matter of minutes the
world will overcome again the time is
high to make it happen faster
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
[Applause]
thank you so much for that moving
address
let me ask you a few questions I know
how impressed you are so thank you in
advance for this and of course let me
extend my condolences and I think
everybody in this audience's condolences
for the terrible tragedy that took place
in Ukraine
in November and December the world
watched with amazement as Ukrainian
forces liberated one town and City for
another
it seems now as though the war has moved
into something that looks more like a
stalemate
can you tell us what the war looks like
to you on the front lines right now
thank you for the question you know
yeah you know afraid thank you for your
condolences by the way
I think
the war doesn't look good
it has not been good since the beginning
and really in winter time it slows down
for known and understandable reasons
everyone gets tired the nature is the
people
and thanks God the enemy too
how it looks
it looks as follows
in the east of our country we are
standing strongly resolutely I am
thankful to all of our Warriors
the living ones the ones that we've
unfortunately lost for The Bravery
it's very important
to know that we are strong not just in
the east of our country but it's really
hot but we are also strong inside the
nation inside our state we are united we
are mobilized because we are motivated
it was not us who started the war but it
is us we will have to end it end it on
our land having it deoccupied with due
respect to our people and our
sovereignty
other parts of our nation
the South the north parts you do control
the situation look at the processes have
slowed down a bit for a variety of
reasons
and it is not just about us keeping
United inside the country we need to
have the whole world United around our
joint failures and because of that we
truly need
s
to continue with that support of Ukraine
to contain you with supplies of
necessary ammunition that we require to
get directory over the enemy of the
battlefield we also need the financial
support limit I'd like to thank all the
nations the European Union for the
support of our budget deficit and
they're continuing there to support us
this year
I also think it is really important
that you know given the energy
challenges that we are seeing and this
these are surely related to disrespect
of the human kinds you know of the
attacks ago against our grades against
over energy sector with Iranian drones
with Russian missiles in order to
instill cows inside the country because
of that you definitely need assistance
from our partners with a defense system
lots of these
I know this is a deficit but I'd like to
thank all many countries worldwide for
their assistance also with Alternative
Energy connectivity solutions from what
it looks like now Russia intends to
get this revenge
and we think that they will succeed
because their fight will not just
Ukraine but the whole
civilized approach towards life thank
you
um yesterday in Davos
um Henry Kissinger suggested that while
Ukraine must be supported and in fact he
came out in favor of Ukraine's
membership in NATO there must also be a
dialogue with Russia because Russia must
be a part of the global order you know
Russia very well you speak Russian
fluently
um what are your thoughts on Russia's
place in the world
[Music]
I
don't know the proper place
when is this show
I think that Russia has already earned a
place among terrorists
and this no longer depends on the
leadership now I think the leaders are
no longer affecting the developments of
Russian Federation its culture and so on
everything depends on the strength of
Ukraine its support by the partners the
political support from the world as well
as from the Russian Society
they have to open their eyes if they
want to see the future of the Russian
Federation with their eyes
they have will have to recognize their
own mistakes they will have to recognize
their young statutes and they will have
to really respect our territorial
Integrity I'm really glad to hear that
Mr Kissinger changed his mind
our priority today our political task
today is to see the different political
leaders and figures those who are still
very relevant so have been relevant
until recently for them to be able to
recognize the great mistake that Putin
committed for them to recognize this is
Russia's aggression
these moments it is very important for
them as well to politically pressure on
Russia to stop this bloody aggression as
regards NATO
we clearly understand that security
guarantees are amount of priorities for
us
speaking of our formula for peace it is
a mother time priorities
they don't understand that at the moment
we are not enough yeah unfortunately
Russia doesn't understand this as well
and they do the damnedest to
not make it easier for us to join but we
are on the way towards later because
NATO is the best security guarantee for
us for our country for our
kids for our country so we have
suggested security guarantees for our
nation and we think that
this civilized world
is going to support our proposals
finally Mr President
the accident or the helicopter crash we
think was an accident we hope it was an
accident but it did raise in my mind and
it of course must have raised in your
mind the question of your own safety
um do you feel that there are still
ongoing active threats that are
increasing uh do you worry about your
own security every day
foreign no I'm not worried about that
I don't have anything to add here
well you you said it you said it once
you don't need uh a ride you need
ammunition right
yeah
nothing has changed we still need
ammunition I'm not enhanced to anything
to anywhere
actually
[Applause]
just to add with your permission
you said accidents
I'd like to tell you that
because of the board experience that I
have now my Society has now
this is not an accident because it has
been due to War and the war
has many dimensions not just from the
battlefields there are no accidents at
wartime these are all war results
absolutely although steps everything
happening missiles striking our
civilians
our kids being killed in kindergartens
at schools
someone might try me who said the
information that it was us who
had our own civilians at the crosshairs
and they were just wanted to hit some
power block and that just a mishap
and this is different
just empty words
every individual every death is a result
of the war
Mr President thank you for your time
you've been very generous best of luck